argelia no tiene margen de error si
quiere seguir luchando por llevarse el
grupo e de la copa africana de naciones
enfrenta en el estadio ya poma de duala
al único equipo hispanohablante del
torneo en guinea ecuatorial los sordos
del desierto últimos campeones del
torneo y dominantes en áfrica en el
último tiempo se encontraron con un
decepcionante empate en el estreno ante
sierra leona un empate sin goles que
mostró ciertas falencias del equipo
argelino que hasta aquí no se habían
visto sin embargo su seleccionador de
amd el vell marí está tranquilo porque
dice que su equipo generó situaciones y
que tiene que simplemente reconciliarse
con el gol para volver a recuperar el
camino de la victoria
en ese sentido recupera también a una
pieza importante el mediocampista email
ven a ser para la zona medular mientras
que del lado del en sala nacional el
equipo ecuatoguineano ha superado ese
brote de kobe 19 que lo complicó para el
debut y recupera todos sus elementos
incluyendo a su seleccionador juanmita
es necesario para el equipo de guinea
ecuatorial empezar a sumar si quiere
mantener opciones de continuar en el
torneo